Hallo und herzlich willkommen zum Chaosradio 272. Mein Name ist Marcus Richter und ich versuche schon seit Jahren durch diese Sendung zu führen. Für mich ist das heute aber eine Premiere, weil meistens ist es so, dass es Dinge gibt, die unsere digitale Welt prägen, bereichern, existent sind und dann tritt jemand dagegen und dann sind die kaputt. Aber es gibt sie zumindest. Und jetzt ist es zumindest, also in meiner Erinnerung das erste Mal, dass etwas im Moment des Erscheinens auch schon wieder verschwindet. Worüber reden wir heute? Wir reden heute über die E-Identität oder den E-Führerschein oder digitale Identität im weitesten Sinne, im staatlichen vor allem. Dazu heiße ich herzlich willkommen einerseits Karl Fabian Lübcke, hallo und guten Tag.
Hallo.
Auch Fluepke genannt und Christian Carlo, hallo und guten Tag.
Ihr seid beide damit beschäftigt, manchmal gegen Dinge zu treten, digitale Sachen zu zerforschen und seid heute hier um uns ein bisschen näher zu erklären, was eigentlich passiert ist. Und ich würde gerne sozusagen aus meiner Perspektive am Anfang anfangen, weil es wirklich so war, ich also wache quasi auf, schaue in meinen Social Media Stream, sehe, aha, es gibt anscheinend jetzt, so vermelden zumindest einige Medien einen elektronischen Führerschein, der irgendwie auf dem Smartphone abgespeichert kann. Und gefühlt im selben Moment kommt die nächste Nachricht, ach nee, gibt es doch nicht. Das ist so kaputt, dass es jetzt wieder weg ist. Ich glaube, in Wirklichkeit war das ein bisschen anders. Und vielleicht sozusagen bis noch ein bisschen mehr Zeit zwischen diesen beiden Sachen vergangen. Aber ich war tatsächlich, obwohl ich mich in diesem Thema relativ gut bewandert, fühle ich mich ein bisschen überrascht, elektronischer Führerschein im Smartphone. Das war mir völlig entgangen, dass überhaupt daran gearbeitet wird. Könntet ihr kurz erklären, wer da welchen Plan hatte und seit wann das Ganze schon im Gange ist?
Also dass man feststellen kann, ob die Software die ist, die sie sein soll und nicht ausgetauscht wurde oder kaputt?
Das ist nochmal wieder was anderes. Da geht es jetzt einfach nur erst mal darum zu prüfen, dass die Funktionalität der Software überhaupt gegeben ist. Da geht es jetzt nicht darum, kryptographisch die Integrität sicherzustellen, sondern erst mal nur zu gucken, so als Qualitätssicherungsmaßnahme funktioniert die App überhaupt. Und das erklärt wahrscheinlich auch, warum die so fürchterlich nicht funktioniert hat, neben den ganzen anderen Sachen wie Überlastung oder dass sie Reserver runtergefahren haben.
Also das Bild, was ich von dieser, ich nenne es jetzt mal Lösung, also das Bild, was ich von dieser Lösung habe, ist das eines Autos, wo man die Motorhaube aufmacht und dann sieht, also statt Motor ist da so ein Hamster in seinem Hamsterrad, der das Ganze antreiben soll, was echt hart wird, weil, naja, da ist schon irgendwie, also da muss schon viel bewegt werden. Das ist sozusagen das Hauptproblem. Aber wenn man um das Auto drumrum geht und sich anguckt, dann ist das eigentlich auch so sehr rostig. Und die Stellen, die stimmen alle nicht. Und die Schrauben sind nicht fest. Und das, naja, ist eigentlich...
Da frage ich mich bei dem Autovergleich ja auch, wieso hat man da nicht einen Kfz-Meister mal draufschauen lassen? Wir haben solche Leute, wir haben halt das BSI. Warum haben die da nicht mehr draufgeschaut und gesagt, halt, stopp, so nicht? Weil das sind halt alles Sachen, die sind eigentlich relativ offensichtlich, wenn man sich damit beschäftigt mit solchen Technologien. Und Lilith und ich haben auch nicht lange gebraucht, irgendwie, um auf die Idee zu kommen, oh, da ist ein QR-Code. Vielleicht könnte man den QR-Code ja irgendwie austauschen, um irgendwie an Identitäten dran zu kommen. Wir haben dann allerdings so anderthalb, zwei Tage gebraucht, uns durch diese schlechtgeschriebene Software und die schlechtgeschriebenen Standards durchzulesen, um tatsächlich so eine Minimalanwendung mal zu implementieren. Und man sollte vielleicht noch dazu sagen, ich habe vorher, bevor ich jetzt in IT-Security arbeite, habe ich als Network-Engineer gearbeitet und als solcher natürlich auch immer mal wieder so Internetstandards gelesen, solche Spezifikationen und daraus Implementationen gebaut. Und das ist halt das, was hier irgendwie abgeliefert wurde, ist irgendwie nicht schön. Und soweit ich weiß, hat Mozilla jetzt auch gerade abgelehnt, dass dieser Standard, also diese Spezifikation zu Decentralized Identities, dass der zum Proposed-Standard wird hat oder irgendwie eine Stufe weitergeht und irgendwie, ja, da gibt's jetzt so eine Timeline, wie irgendwie solche Standards entwickelt werden und dann irgendwie publiziert werden. Und da hat Mozilla gesagt, so halt stopp, das geht jetzt erst mal in den Anfangsstatus zurück. Wir finden das irgendwie nicht gut. Microsoft findet das irgendwie nicht gut, Google findet das nicht gut. Und da ist jetzt gerade irgendwie auch sehr viel Diskussion am Gange irgendwie um dieses ganze Decentralized Identity Ding.
Okay, also da wird noch eine Zeit ins Land gehen, bevor das wirklich funktioniert. Ich hätte noch eine letzte Frage, Fluepke. Und das ist, jetzt ist es ja so, wenn man sich Dinge öffentlicher Stellen anguckt, dann reagieren die ja manchmal nicht mit vielen lieben Dank, dass sie die Arbeit gemacht haben, für die wir eigentlich hätten teuer jemand bezahlen müssen. Wir werden das sofort bessern. Sondern das kippt ja manchmal ins Gegenteil. Man kriegt dann Strafanzeigen oder so Dinge ins Haus. Ist euch da irgendwas Negatives widerfahren nach der Veröffentlichung? Also außer das, was du erzählt hast, dass sie komplett ignoriert haben, was ihr gesagt habt?
Ja, also wir wurden da erstmal ignoriert. Dann wurden wir in einem Dokument des Herstellers und des Bundeskanzleramts beleidigt, als eine politisch motivierte Zusammenrottung mit Hacking-Affinität und dem Ziel, eine negative Öffentlichkeit zu erzielen für das Ding. Also der Hersteller, keine Ahnung, ist da irgendwie nicht auf Augenhöhe unterwegs. Dann gibt es von einzelnen Menschen aus dieser SSI Community, die versuchen einen einzuschüchtern oder öffentlich zu verleumden. Das sind aber einzelne Personen. Ansonsten ist bisher nichts Schlimmes, nichts Böses passiert. Ich sitze hier noch in meiner Wohnung, die bisher noch nicht geradet wurde. Aber so eine Strafanzeige, die dauert natürlich auch ein bisschen. Von daher ist es, denke ich, am jetzigen Zeitpunkt noch zu früh darüber zu sprechen, ob da dann noch was kommt. Dass es keine Reaktion von keiner der Gegenseiten gab, spricht schon mal eher dafür, dass man nicht an einem Diskurs interessiert ist. Und dass da eventuell auch noch was zu befürchten ist.
Drücke euch auf jeden Fall die Daumen, dass das nicht passiert. Vielen Dank, CK, vielen Dank Fluepke, dass ihr heute da wart und geduldig Ertragen habt, wie ich immer wieder unterbreche, wie ich versuche zu erklären, was da genau passiert ist. Aber ich hoffe, es hat dazu beigetragen, dass man jetzt verstehen kann, was da genau passiert ist. Warum das ID Wallet und die ganzen ähnlichen Lösungen in ihrer derzeitigen Form momentan eher ein Problem sind als eine Lösung. Ihr, liebe Hörerinnen, vielen Dank fürs Zuhören. Wenn es euch gefallen hat, tragt uns weiter oder kommentiert fleißig. Ansonsten habe ich heute nur noch eine Sache zu sagen, und das ist, wie immer, lasst euch nicht überwachen und verschüsselt immer schön eure Backups.